I'm somewhere where is I'm sorry John
where's Nick
what there's Nick Nick Oh mr. Kroll is
here somewhere but we mean he's here
somewhere
well I don't speak for mr. Kroll you
don't speak for mr. Kroll that's know it
I don't this is I don't I I know he's in
the building I walked out you announced
us I don't we bought both with you I
said you were supposed to be here it was
supposed to be jolly
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I'm sorry what's what was that all
about mr. maleeni and I are not speaking
currently we are currently not speaking
to each other yeah you're not speaking
to each other you just finished four
months together on Broadway yeah that
was a long time ago Conan yeah no it was
not a long time ended January 22nd
that's in the past
yes sir parole and I are not speaking
yeah we are currently in litigation with
one another I'm in litigation with mr.
Mulaney yeah hence the mr. Kroll in the
mr. Mulaney all right wait you're suing
each other is that right it's a falling
out cone yeah all right like Simon and
Garfunkel or Colin Colin Oh Hall & Oates
did that we don't talk to we don't talk
you just talk to each other right there
lied no we didn't know I don't know turn
the roof don't turn this on this is a
classic falling out like Sasha and Malia
okay did not speak anymore yeah okay so
there's a there's a lawsuit is this
anything to do with Jon you wrote a
tell-all book does that have anything to
do with it write this I felt the need to
set the record straight and Knick Knack
this guy's wack give the Freak a bone
okay there's a question mark there but I
can tell you the answer yes all right I
wanted to go first title of any Punk
well I wanted to call it's a beautiful
jacket we did it in about a half hour on
a computer ha ha I wanted to call it mr.
lousy aka Admiral jerk but I you can't
have profanity on book okay this is a
children's show I don't know what's even
happening here so you wrote this book
that's what caused the problem it's one
of the many I mean I I was personally
offended by it you know but it goes way
back I mean this goes deep this is
you know mr. Mulaney and he stole me I
had a drug problem you had a heroin I
had a drug problem
heroin wasn't the only drug I was there
and
mr. parole is correcting that he was
abusing other things other than okay
then I say this guy's life I take him to
the best rehab you know Trump's doctor I
take him to back
I saved this guy's life dr. Harold
Bornstein I believe that's the name yeah
my line guys save my life
so I get out of rehab I find a great
woman Sookie she's my girl animal person
and then she starts looking at the books
she sees that Mulaney and mr. maleeni
are stealing money from I wanted to
stealing money I mean this is oh hello
this is hundreds of dollars we're
talking this bent you know you say
Hollywood's a ruthless place this guy
stole a role from me it was a brioche
and I wanted I had the butter out okay
okay sourdough would have been funnier I
don't know and so and what else have you
guys done it was a radio went on the
radio I was furious joy went on the
radio and I acted out okay and I don't
regret it it was I went on Stern oh okay
you went on the Howard Stern Show no I
went on Daniel Stern's radio show he was
a narrator from the Wonder yes Daniel
Stern De Niro The Wonder Years
he has a radio show yeah yeah is we got
the clip you got a clip from that let's
play the clip yeah but what John doesn't
say in the book is that he drinks so
much coffee that is France doesn't work
the guy's got a classic case of caffeine
as' is standing there that winter
afternoon
new things would be alright No
you know I can't believe that you're
fighting because you guys have been
coming on my show since 1997 since 1997
follow them now what are you doing here
you kind of bring up old times that we
cry Fonzie like you've been coming on
since 99 I'm gonna show guess what I'm
gonna show a picture your appearance on
1995
come on no offense we caught and could
we do our bit and then Cody calls his
own anyway
Conan would give you the thumbs up in
the okay sign in the hang ten yeah
that meant to come over to the couch if
you were an infant that was the big deal
was a big thing you had to give love
rather than roll around on the couch I
could put my foot in my mouth back then
and I don't mean misspeak I could fit my
vision was a so those are the great and
this is what he's doing though he's
trying to try to remind us of what we
were yeah this guy he's worthless is
this guy try a cup here you try to you
see have you ever seen you you wear your
leather jacket off yeah my lens off
hammer 11 this guy is a joke we've been
fighting with each other when really the
problem is Conan's offstage this casual
casual mode you're a father get a tweed
jacket I came and saw your show I came
backstage we have a picture of me
backstage hanging with you guys alright
the leather-clad what are the Tuskegee
Airmen alright
you dating a pink lady right now come on
all right well the important thing is
you're back together now right I love
you
[Applause]
you